what happened in 1979 in Iran well in
1979
there was
a revolution that eventually came to be
known as the Islamic revolution and even
up to this day
many of The Observers or those who have
strong views that would not like to
refer to it as an Islamic revolution or
even a revolution
this is the because the nature of it in
the earlier stages of it started really
probably around 1977 it took two years
was much more all embracing it was not
Islamic in a particular fashion or at
all in a sense it started with a kind of
a very liberal Democrats
uh agenda
which required which demanded mostly by
people who were the veterans of the
older generations of Iranian liberal
nationalists that were left out in the
palabi period it's a period of the Shah
uh became increasingly authoritarian
increasing the suppressive
and therefore basically living no space
no political space
open for any kind of a give and take
any kind of a conversation or
participation 2017 70s 70s particularly
in the 70s can we actually even like
just do a a whirlwind review from 1906
to 1979 okay sure in 1906 there was a
period like actually as you might know
the first decade or this so of of the
20th century witnessed numerous what's
referred to as constitutional
revolutions including Russia 1905 the
first Revolution
including the Chinese Revolution in 90
constitution in 1910 the young Texas
Revolution in 1908 and the Iranian
Revolution in 1906. to understand why
the synchronicity of all of it why in so
many different places very different
cultures very different governments very
different cultures but all of them in a
sense were coming out of
the regime that became uh uh
progressively powerful
without having any kind of a legal
system that would protect the individual
vis-a-vis state so the idea of law
and the Constitution According to which
there should be a certain protection a
certain Civil Society became very common
yeah but I wonder where that because
that's been that way for for a very very
long time and so I wonder
you know it's funny a certain ideas just
their time comes exactly it's like 1848
when you would see that there's a whole
range of revolutions
across Europe yeah or you would see for
instance the Arab Spring you see all
these Revolutions in the Arab world
which unfortunately nearly all of them
failed
so yes these are very contagious ideas
that moves across Frontiers from one
culture to another and I presume we can
add to that there are two elements which
one can say there is positive greater
communication there is the greatest
sense of a world economy and the third
of the century witnessed the first
decade of the century witnessed a period
of uh volatility particularly in uh in
currency
so many of the countries of the world
particularly non-west
suffered in and
particularly the businesses suffered
and not surprisingly the business class
were in the Forefront of many of these
constitutional movements requiring the
state to give the a kind of a created
the right kind of Institutions to listen
to their voices to their concerns and
the creation of the democratic system
parliamentary and system in which there
would be a representation
popular representation proper elections
and so forth and constitutions and this
very much is a kind of a French idea of
the Constitution going back all the way
perhaps to 1789 Revolution
Montesquieu all this kind of philosoph
were greatly appreciated particularly a
different system so what were the ideas
in the 1906 Iranian Constitution they
precisely the same they were demanding a
creation of a legal system with division
of power between the three
executive
legislative and the Judiciary and that's
unlike the American system
and they requested
um basically a certain uh public space
to be created between the two sources of
power the state which had this kind of a
control over the if you like the secular
aspect of life in the society and the
religious establishment that had a full
control over the religious aspects and
both of them from the perspective of the
Constitution and this considered as
repressive and therefore there has to be
a new space open between these two
and that was the idea of a
constitutional Revolution but but it's
very nature it was an idea of modernity
they wanted the modern society they
wanted a better material life they they
wanted a more representation and and so
forth the Constitutional Revolution
as I always would say is much more of a
innocent Revolution it's a revolution
that did not particularly have much
violence in it contrary to many other
revolutions
it did not have a centralized leadership
per se that's why actually I'm getting I
mean besides the parenthesis I'm getting
a lot of requests for interviews to
compare what's happening now with the
revolution of 1906
1909 are there any Echoes yes yes there
are there are because that was a
movement that started without a without
a centralized leadership
what actually values to voices
that emerged in various among the
merchants or the businessmen in the
economic Community among the
representatives who came to the first
Parliament the Press
the new generation of the privileged
aristocracy
who were educated and believed in the
Constitutional values all of these
voices emerged at the same time and
somehow they managed to
uh to coexist
in the first and the second uh
uh parliaments that were created uh
between 1905 6 and 1910 or 1911.
but they all face huge problems
in the sense that Iran was in a dire
economic situation this is before the
days of the discovery of oil but
actually the coincides with this card
there are two important coincidences one
is that the oil was discovered in the
south in 1909
during the course of the Constitutional
Revolution the second is that in 1907
the two great powers of the time the
Russian Empire and the British Empire
who always honored Iran as being a
buffer State between them because they
didn't want to get too close to one
another
basically came to an agreement facing
the fear of the rise of the German
Empire so this is the period of Anton as
you might know in European history
whereby the front the French the British
and the Russians all create a
Alliance that ultimately leads to the
first world war against Germany and at
the same time the discovery of oil that
the oil industry being a very powerful
defining factor of the 20th century for
Iran exactly source of a lot of money a
lot of money but not all of it in the
hands of the Iranians only 150 of it by
way of royalties came to Iran there is
much of it went to the Anglo
passion a oil company which they
actually discovered the oil in the
province who was the star province in
the southwest of Iran raise the major
oil Industries today right now
and
this is an extremely profitable uh
Enterprise for that company and for the
British government it actually purchased
by the British government Churchill
purchased anglo-iranian oil company for
the British government so it was not
anymore a private company it was a
British interest as a matter of fact and
in the course of the 20th century
although it helped the modernization in
Iran but it also helped the creation of
a more authoritative Syria more
strong state if you like to call it
that it does that 19th century I never
had that kind of a power never had that
kind of resources it is it 20th century
even that one-fifth of the income that
reached the Iranian State gave it a
greater power that's another coincidence
so yes yes you could say the oil was one
of the catalysts for absolute power but
the 20th century saw quite a few
countries
um have dictators with power unlike
anything else in human history yes
that's weird too
precisely and you know you can name them
from the beginning of the century with
people like
um I don't know Lenin or Stalin of
course Hitler even now Mao of course you
can name them and probably as I would
say is the last of them is Khomeini in
that Century that you would see this
strong man
with a sense of even a a a artificial or
real or a sense of so-called Charisma
and with this total power over the
regime that they create in the some of
them do Nasir they didn't have much of
an oil resources in Egypt but he was
also one of these strong men okay in the
20th century loved by some hated by
others uh so it necessarily does not tie
up to
uh to Resource economic resources
underground but in the Iranian case
unfortunately it did
and it was a uh it was more than it
created more than one issue for Iran
it's created a strong state which is the
palavi state from 1920 born onward
because in 1921 at the end of the first
world war Iran was in a almost a state
of total bankruptcy
and uh the British had a desire to try
to bring Iran to the system that they
created in the Middle East in the
postwater era the mandate system
Palestine Iraq and then of course French
Mandate of Lebanon and Syria all of this
and Iran was separate because Iran was
an independent country it wasn't part of
the ottawan Empire that collapsed
so they had to somehow handle it
and what they tried to do didn't work
as a result
partly domestic partly international
issues brought about a regime which is
headed by the founder of the
Parliamentary
okay the first military officer called
Reza Khan actually a military officer of
the Kozak forces and the Kozak forces
was the force that was created in the
19th century model of the Russian kozaks
when the ruler in the 19th century
visited Russia as in a Royal tour and
the desire should the Great
uh Kozak forces is that I like this and
he created one for himself with Russian
officers actually so the Russian
officers served in Iran from Iran
1880s up to the revolution of 1917. the
collapse of the yeah so many revolutions
so many revolutions and Reza shop was an
officer in that there's a Khan was an
officer in that first and he created a
new monarchy for reasons that we needed
to go to and Discord the palavi regime
regime was a modernizing regime
okay that brought a company in effect
fulfilled many of the Ambitions of the
Constitution many of the aspirations of
the Constitution better communication
but uh secular education
um centralizes States and centralized
Army
better contact with the outside world
greater urbanization that's what a
modern state is all about
and in that regard in a sense for the
first 20 years up to the second world
war was successful
despite and more significant of all it
managed to keep the European powers
which is always interfering in the local
Affairs of Iran in an arm legs so they
were there
in an arm length
but they were also
respecting the power of the state
part of the Apollo State during the
second second world war the same
phenomenon
as
earlier interference led to the
occupation of Iran by the Allied Forces
the British from the south the Russians
from the north
the Red Army they took over Iran and of
course the second world war yes from
1941 up to 1945 and of course when the
when the Red Army refused to
uh withdraw from Iranian Azerbaijan
and with some
thought of possible annexation of
that Province there was a big issue in
the post-wire Iran so after 1945 yes
1945 to 1946 there was a big
Soviet Union getting greedy yes but
eventually they agreed eventually Stalin
agreed to leave
the Azerbaijan province in the hope that
it would get some concessions from Iran
which in the oil of the Caspian era area
which didn't work and it's a different
story altogether but what happened is
that in the post-war era
between
1944 45 and 1953 is a period of Greater
uh democratization was that
vessels dictatorship basically
disappeared
and this is where you would see
political parties Free Press
a lot of chaotic really
as as democracies often are so something
like was it was it officially a
democracy yes it was it the market was
there elections there were elections yes
of course yes of course and they were
very diverse political tendencies
came to the picture including the to the
party of Iran which is Communist Party
of Iran this Communist Party of Iran is
probably the biggest
Communist Party of the whole of the
Middle East and one of the biggest in
the world actually at that time did the
Soviet Union have a significant
influence on uh of course we're
basically following orders from the
Soviets although they deny it but in
reality that's the case yeah but what
happened they were seen by the Americans
during the Cold War as if as a threat
and Iran was going through a period of
demanding nationalization of his oil
resources that's a very important
episode with mosadir whom you might have
heard about his name Dr Muhammad Musa
was the Prime Minister and the national
charismatic leader
from
1951 to 1953 prior to that it was a
famous parliamentarian but this period
was the Prime Minister of Iran anti
nationalized the Iranian oil industry
and the British didn't like it at all
and eventually resulted in a famous crew
which at least partly was supported by
the funding
and by the moral support of the British
and the Americans particularly by the
emergence it was always
seen as one of the earliest and the most
successful CIA operations during the
Cold War to see I had something to do
with this of course that's one of the
earliest operations of the CIA wait a
minute what was yes of course what was
the same what was the CIA doing CIA this
is the time at the post for era in the
50s in the 50s 40s and the 50s
the British Empire which was really the
major superpower of the region after the
collapse of the desires Empire
gradually took the second
seat
to the Americans to where the newcomers
and the great powers and the victors of
the second World War
and the Americans viewed Iran as an
important
uh uh as an important country since it
has the largest uh common borders with
the Soviet Union
and it was I did the size was the
Persian goldfish at the time was the
greatest uh uh supplier of uh oil to the
outside world and therefore the
Americans uh had a particular interest
in Iraq and in the earlier stages their
interest was in the interest of the
Iranian government because they wanted
to get rid of both
the Soviet Union which made the return
in the first War era and of course the
British that were gradually withdrawing
from Iraq but they they had a full
control over the anglo-iranian or
company they changed the name to angular
Iranian or company
when the name of the country officially
changed from Persia to Iran
in the west
the name of the company changed and they
got into a huge dispute with the wasada
government that eventually led to the
coup of 1953 which eventually created it
very
uh very distressful memory
in the minds of many of the Iranian
nationalists that this was the betrayer
of the great Powers the British and
Americans yes CIA played a part because
see I feared
contrary to the British that they were
afraid of their own oil in Iran the CIA
was afraid of the Soviet penetration in
in the South and particularly because
there was a very powerful political very
powerful Communist party you know the
two-day party of Iran
so they
gradually shifted between the Truman
Administration and our Eisenhower
Administration these are early days of
the CIA and then they actually did
participate uh to send their agents
there's a long story to that and it
eventually resulted in a successful coup
that removed from Power what's the
United States interest here why are they
using CIA are they trying to make sure
there's not too much centralization of
power in this region they were afraid of
the fact that the
that of the Soviet Union and during the
Cold War that was the concerned they
actually almost want to protect Iran and
its own Sovereign processes from the
influence of the Soviets yes because
they were afraid of the fact
if Iran or at least this is part of the
I'm simplifying a very complex picture
but the but but the Americans basically
were thinking that if Iran is going to
be lost
true Soviet influence
then eventually basically the all the
oil resources in the Persian Gulf are
going to be threatened
and therefore and this would basically
is the National Security of the United
States and all of the western allies
European allies
so in a sense this was the long arm of
the CIA to try to
try to make sure that that's not going
to happen and then of course they were
persuaded by the British because British
were the old hands which were in Iran
since the beginning of the 19th century
they always had relations with Iran and
so forth so they gradually replaced and
of course they don't want to give them
this kind of a satanic view that
American was a bad influence because
they had also some very good influences
in Iraq but this particular episode
somehow
shared dark lights
on the American presence and was used
that abused time and again particularly
the revolution
1979 which was this great Satan idea
that Khomeini created basically was
based on the fact is
1953 you were responsible for the
downfall of a national government in
Iran which as a matter of fact he had no
respect for it how many had no respect
for the national secular National
liberals including Muhammad Masada but
he was using it as a as the rhetorical
tool for his own purposes but what
happened is that after 1953
we see again the rise of authoritarian
Maha mattress that show us power
and then he is that's the Shah that's
the Shah that we know as sure this is
the son of research and uh technically
what what is Shah is it actually is an
old term impression
that comes from a pre-islamic person of
ancient times in the context of
democracy should it be seen as like a
supreme leader King is the head of the
executive power according to the
Constitution of 1906. oh that's in the
Constitution they actually yeah he has a
place in the Constitution but the actual
term sure okay interesting what this
show is a very old term yeah it's almost
like a monarchic term like uh like a
king yeah it is actually is the term
peculiar to Iran I've written about it
somewhere but because the term that the
Western World in the ancient times has
been Rex for royalty and the King
in the Eastern World in India is right
it's the same origin the same route
Iran never shared that they had the idea
of it because the extended I don't want
to get into the too much of a etymology
but this is an interesting one yeah Rex
and Raj both means the one that opens
the road for
basically in four set of religion okay
um in uh enforcer of the right religion
because Rex and Raj both have the uh of
the a typological uh origin of Rights
you see and right means the right
religion basically by the way there's so
much beautiful language here I'm just
looking at the the Persian constitution
in 1906 and it says it's the
constitution of the sublime state of
Persia pajar Iran I mean just just the
extra adjectives on top of this stuff is
beautiful I mean yeah because that was
actually the change that came about I
don't want to go in too much into it but
it was called as I pointed out before
the guarded domains of Iraq yes they
changed that to the sublime state of
Iran during the Constitutional
Revolution because they wanted to give a
greater sense of centrality of this
state yeah and Sublime was the term
refused but also what permeates all this
is a is a poetic I mean there is a
history of poetry of course based on the
culture but it's just fascinating so I
mean it's I I of course I don't speak
the language but even in in Russian
there's also
a music
to the soul of the people that
represents itself that presents itself
in the form of poetry and literature in
a way that it doesn't in the in the
English-speaking world I don't know what
that is there's um there's a Romantics
like Romantics romantic side that's
right yeah I agree with you in Iran of
course you know there's a time of the
Constitutional Revolution is a time of
great poetry
this kind of a patriotic
sentiments that comes through poetry
plays a very important part uh of course
these days poetry has kind of declined
and instead you see the visual image
that is at the center that's why Cinema
is so important because these days with
their Tick Tock yeah let me finish this
about this period of biometricia he
built up because he received the greater
income
from the oil revenue and it built up a
very strong state with a strong security
Force
it strong security apparatus which is
the savark there's a which is a acronym
for the security force in security
organization
and here of course unfortunately in the
1960s and 70s particularly 1970s
basically suppress the voices of or the
possibility of any kind of a mass
participation in the political uh
process it became very much an
authoritarian regime with its own
technocrats
very much a modernist
vision of of of of
Iran's future and almost kind of
Messianic that he was hoping that Iran
in a decade would become the fifth most
powerful estate in the world and the
riches as he would have said the gates
of the great civilization very much in
the mind
had this image of ancient Iran of the
community Empire and we want to go back
to that greatness of the archimedian
Empire somewhat rather naive and very
nationalistic and crude fashion and what
happened is that as a result there was
built up some kind of a resistance from
the intellectuals from the left
eventually resulting in a kind of a
protest movement as I said by 1977 1978.
then of course the question that comes
to mind and the probably it you have you
you would like to know about is the fact
that why it becomes religious why it's
become Islamic if it's the popular
you know nationalist liberal tendency of
opening up the political uh uh space
and along the greater participation
going back to the Constitution
of 1906 1907 why it's all of a sudden it
becomes Khomeini where does he come from
the reason for that at least in a
concise fashion is the fact that on one
area
that
after the greatest suppression of all
the other voices remained
open was religion masks
the mullahs on the pulpit
and the message that gradually shifted
from the older traditional message of
the Sharia of Islam I mean all the rules
and regulations of how one has to live
into something very political
and not only political but also radical
political
so
in the whole period from the
Constitutional Revolution to the
revolution of 1979
basically the religious establishment
gradually was pushed to the opposition
they were not originally very
conservative supported us of State as
the Catholic church for instance was
supported of majority of the
authoritarian governments around the
world
but the politicization
was the result of isolation
because they were left out of the system
and while in isolation they did they did
not they were not successful
in
trying to reform themselves to try to
become to try to find answers to many of
the questions from Modern Times what
happens to women what happens to civil
rights what happens to a civil society
how the modern law and individual
freedoms have to be defined in Islamic
terms how to separate uh religion and
state or how to separate the religion
and state these issues were never
addressed
what happened is that there was this
bypass through political
uh Islam and
revolutionary Islam as it gradually they
learned you know that this is the bypass
bypass to power basically to become
again a voice in the society and
eventually a prominent voice and
eventually monolithic voice and the
society that's the process that led into
the revolution of 1979 basically this
period
greater attention was paid to religion
even among the secular middle classes
who were alienated
for a very long time because of this
extensive modernization of the pallavi
period they had they didn't have a sense
of that old
monoliths with their turbans
but they became they had it kind of aura
in this period yes they are those who
remain not corrupted
they are the people who basically went
against the suppression of the palavi
regime and Khomeini became a leader a
symbol of that nobody ever thought in
the earlier stages
among this very excited multitudes that
came to the streets of the Iranian
cities in 1979 or 1978 actually
thought that this this old ball line
with 70s
that all of a sudden has appeared from
the najaf
through Paris to Tehran is going to take
over and create a autocracy a religious
autocracy